je m'appelle cynthia où mahut ma mère
est à moitié chinoise donc moi je suis
encore chinoise vous le dites vous même
vous êtes un bébé d'un restaurant
chinois parce que votre arrière grand
parent votre grand père sont arrivés au
québec vous avez grandi à trois rivières
alors comment vous êtes devenue
comédienne parce que si vous avez eu le
déclic dans le restaurant benghazi mais
je pensais j'ai eu la piqûre je pense du
public logique j'ai baigné là dedans
mais ma mère vous voyez que j'avais une
fibre artistique puis il y avait le
centre communautaire à trois rivières
sont multiples us plus j'y vais toujours
essayer un pro théâtre c'est ok puis
j'ai commencé tout à fait à mon dieu je
comprends je comprends cette matière
c'est donc bien étrange puis j'avais du
fun à explorer ce puits a essayé de
jouer avec soupe puis j'ai fait un clip
je vais te reprendre une autre session
avant la fête aux mollahs doivent être
sortis du conservatoire d'art dramatique
vous avez pas chômé parce que une
tactique en gagnant ce prix donne envie
va peut-être voir vous aider à trouver
un meilleur local et cinq alliés sur la
série pro long comment tu l'as vu tracer
votre chemin à écouter bain puis avance
j'ai commencé dans un champ de la dinde
à c'est à saint jean sur richelieu sa
forme d'humilité que j'ai fait plusieurs
petits rôles aussi qu'ils étaient des
personnages d'un épisode avec réplique
ou peu mais tellement iphone afin qu'il
n'y ait pas de petits rôles clairement
oui mais là je pense pour une baie
l'effrontée votre road d'actia bernard
dans l'industrie 31 3 saisons quand même
marqué l'imaginaire collectif surtout la
finale sanglante plus terrifiant
schricke avec le recul comment voyez
cette expérience le fabuleux jusqu'à
celle de travail sur le plateau de
district et oui vraiment est un cadeau
c'est un cadeau extraordinaire
personne ne s'attendait à ce que ça
devienne aussi groupe tuons parti c'est
nouveau on essayait tout le monde essaie
de faire de son mieux à la recherche de
ses personnages de cet univers la tv
avec c'est sûr que ça donnait une
visibilité
hillman style vraiment ce qu'ils avaient
déjà quand même commencé avec trauma
quand même avec tactique puis la part du
cinquième parce que le style et des
adolescents et les jeunes ainsi qu'il
reconnaissait voir des petits dieux
qu'ils reconnaissent et bouchard c'est
tellement vous vous êtes aussi récemment
impliqué dans la campagne découvrons
nous c'est important pour vous de parler
de diversité qu'on voit plus de
diversité à l'écran
ben ouais c'est année c'est moi comme
demandé de prendre parole
c'est quelque chose en plus qui me
demandent beaucoup dans ce sens que je
suis quelqu'un d'un peu timide fait
vraiment quelque chose que j'apprends à
développer mais j'avoue que c'est venu
me chercher un niveau que je pensais pas
émotionnellement la waho c6 est venu me
des balances je me suis rendu compte que
c'était que c'est un sujet qui était
plus
plus sensible pour moi que je le pensais
que c'était beau c'était beau à ce
niveau là aussi il m'attire je sais pas
et voilà à regarder votre feuille de
route on voit que vous avez travaillé
dans certaines productions à savoir
sociale quand même je pense à
consentement jeudi le consentement
sexuel
oui absolument ce genre de rôle qui est
tu viens me chercher
ben oui a tellement de niveaux puis je
pense était avec sarah berthiaume yukon
style il ya aussi en fait le rêveur dans
son bain au tnm
on est en train de préparer un
laboratoire c'est exactement ça aussi
c'est un sur deux deux missions sociales
un peu sur leurs questionnements de
l'art dans la société et de l'artiste
dans la société de commun est ce qu'au
nom du génie on accepte que l'être
humain peut être un peu exécrable si
vous n'acceptez vous c'est encore en
réflexion c'est pas un oui clair c'est
pas un non clair parce que c'est sûr que
c'est ça qui est difficile parce que ces
personnes la porte des oeuvres qui vient
de toucher à des nouveaux démesuré mais
tu regardes l'humain petit fait ben
voyons c'est le moment de la question du
champ gauche dans votre curriculum vitae
vous écrivez que vous aimez la danse des
marionnettes le convoque le camp fouet
le tricot la passe comme fou tricot
novembre à prendre mais j'écoute mais je
sais pas si quelqu'un de très curieux
très curieuse et j'aime essayer
d'essayer été autant je pense c'est ce
qui m'a fait choisir ce métier l'été
j'ai le droit de tout faire on a droit
de tout faire même du tricot même du
tricot d'être côtés d'air de faire un
combat de se promener en nature de
devenir marie curie ok on le fait on
essaye ok on joue cynthia ou meurs merci
beaucoup merci merci beaucoup
une démence fronto-temporale avec le
trouble affectif bipolar qu'il a
dr les guerriers voulu voyager mais moi
je me suis dit que ça l'aide pire si je
la prenais plus tard